[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report at presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside live
moves
welcome back liv how you feeling today
feeling good excited to be back talking
talking with you about the nba we're in
the heat of the playoffs obviously both
of our teams are playing tonight i'm
sure one of us feels a whole lot better
than the other one does and we'll get to
that but nonetheless excited to be back
here with you for sure
excited to be back liv you've been all
over the country all over the globe
but i don't mean to brag liv you were in
back here but i don't mean to brag but
my warriors are killing it right now and
i'm feeling like santa claus in april
today so i'm giving away locks giving
away but he's also giving away some
jerseys and those brand new br betting
basketball shorts that i do not have a
pair of i need to get a pair of those so
get in the comments i need gifts i need
emojis but most importantly i need
winners only please but i'm giving out
some of those shorts right now liv i'm
in the comments i am in the comments
looking for takes looking for good takes
uh i got
not danny devito he's asking a question
he's asking it to everybody he said is
pool a splash brother now
i think yes shout out to you you are
walking away with those pair of shorts
for mentioning the golden state warriors
for mentioning splash brothers and
mentioning jordan pool but all right you
guys it's tnt thursday so you already
know
us over here at br betting we are
betting the three by two the question is
will there be two three pointers in the
first three minutes of the game we asked
you on twitter
which three by two will cash tonight is
it
memphis the grizzlies taking on the
wolves the mavs taking on the jazz or is
it the warriors taking on the nuggets
and here are the results liv
there they are and i'm not surprised
steph curry clay thompson i mean we
could talk about the nuggets too jokic
will barton they have players that can
make the three ball so i'm not surprised
but liv what are you thinking
yeah i'm not surprised at all where this
is at and i do agree with the public
here like you said uh the splash
brothers now triplets with jordan pool
have a lot of three-point shooters and
the nuggets are currently giving up the
most three-pointers to put to their
opposing teams um that being the
warriors in the playoffs right now so
their perimeter defense is definitely
lacking but i do think there is some
value in that wolves versus grizzlies
one as well that one's at plus money
you've got guys like d lo that are bound
to heat up john moran desmond bain has
been an efficient three-point shooter
for the grizzlies anthony edwards is
going to heat up carl anthony towns won
the three-point contest in all-star
weekend in cleveland so i do think great
value there with the timberwolves and
the grizzlies might be worth a sprinkle
especially at plus money but i'm with
the public i like the warriors and the
nuggets tonight
liv i like i like that first nugget that
you dropped on the t wolves grizzlies
game uh that over under is kind of high
so we might see a lot of scoring there
so i like the nugget but uh let me hop
into these comments let me hop into
these comments because i'm giving out
hoodies i'm giving out hoodies
uh
i see hammer hammer
1010 says y'all cool but as good as my
wife that's not a good thing earlier i
have no idea what that means uh i got b
scott sands warriors 3x2 with easy money
shout out to you
warrior scott you were walking away with
a hoodie richie 21 says warriors locking
that
on their own uh so he says the warriors
are hitting the 3x2 on their own shout
out to you richie21 you are also rocking
walking away with a hoodie uh liv it is
a pair we are riding the 3x2 with you
we're riding the 3x2 with the results
within the app we are riding the denver
nuggets golden states warriors 3x2 all
as a family but right now liv it is part
it's time for my favorite part of the
show let's talk major markets money
lines against the spreads and point
totals for tonight's game let's take a
look at the odds there they are liv what
are you thinking here anything that
sticks out to you
yeah you know what this may be a head
versus heart battle i may be doing this
based off of my emotions and where my
heart lies but i am absolutely rocking
with the nuggets plus two and a half no
apologies for it if it is a heart bet i
don't care the nuggets have their back
against the wall we have seen them many
times before twice actually where they
have been down three nothing in a series
and come back and won so back against
the wall i like jokic to score a whole
lot better tonight aaron gordon to be
more aggressive will barton to continue
his offensive role on this team back
against the wall here nuggets to cover
plus two and a half at home this may be
the only win the game the only game they
keep close or win in this series but i'm
backing my nuggets nuggets plus two and
a half no regrets it is what it is
liv is rocking with her home team and
and liv i'm honestly i'm not mad at you
because i i i would do the same thing if
the rose was was if the rose was
reversed i would definitely be doing the
same thing but i wanted to look at that
first game i want to look at that first
game i'll let you have your shine in the
same game but that first game i see a
home underdog there it is they pulled it
back up for us i see a home underdog
minnesota plus to live there is a lot
and i mean a lot of money on the memphis
grizzlies so this is
a fade play we are fading the public
here yesterday i went live on my ig live
on br betting and a lot of people and i
mean a lot of people were mentioning the
brooklyn nets the brooklyn that's the
brooklyn nets and guess what liv we all
saw it the brooklyn nets did not show up
yesterday so the public is once again on
the grizzlies i am rocking the other way
and i'm taking the home favorite in the
minnesota timberwolves live we know
about the playoff drought we know how
their fans are gonna be out there in
minnesota they're gonna be loud they're
gonna be turned
and i'm taking the spread in that game i
am rocking with the spread but let me
get into the comments let me see what
they are talking about which way they
are
i see braden reagan braden reagan 2-6
has the memphis grizzlies he gave us a
gift shout out to you brayden you're
walking away with a hoodie you're you're
fading my pick but that is okay uh i see
ak ak-47 big blue says taking nuggets
and wolves winning and both over wow
that is a big parlay if that hits you
you might be walking away with a lot of
money shout out to you i got one more
one more visionary says curry's
definitely dropping over 21 points
tonight so shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you all are walking away with
hoodies all right liv we talked to major
markets now let's talk
player props it's time for lock or not
i'm gonna put up a prop and i need all
of you to get in the comments and tell
me whether it is a lot or it's not
and you know what liv
our teams are facing off tonight so
let's talk warriors nuggets
i'll be nice i'll be nice we're starting
off with nicola yoke so we'll start off
with a denver nugget i'll be nice
will he score over 29 points tonight
it's sitting at minus 116. talk to me
talk to the people
yeah i'm gonna say it's a lock because
he really doesn't have a choice tonight
he has to score better if the nuggets
want to hang in this game with the
warriors and or win this game against
the warriors uh 29 plus for jokic in the
regular season was like you didn't even
bat an eye at it it was like okay yeah
he's gonna drop 30 plus nobody's worried
about it so we need to see that same
energy from jokic back tonight if the
nuggets want to do anything in this game
so i'm going to say it's a lock because
again nuggets have their backs against
the wall jokic is that guy and he has to
score better in game three than he did
in game one in game two so i'm gonna say
it's a lock because he doesn't have a
choice
liv i'm right there behind you i'm now
i'm not saying that they're gonna win
i'm not saying that but i do think my
manny jokic
is gonna have a game today i mean he
scored 26 and 25 in games one and two he
was kicked out of game two so uh i can
see him beat like focusing up on this
being the focal point of the offense
early for the nuggets
and getting those points so i can see
him actually hitting this 29 mark pretty
easy but that does not mean that they
are going to win uh let me hop into the
comments let me hop into the comments uh
i see
richie 21 is back in the comments he
says yes that is a lock he has to go all
out shout out to you
jr bath says that is a lock he is
rocking with me you and he was rocking
with me and he is rocking with you liv
shout out to you you are walking away
with the hoodie next up we have draymond
green to have over
seven rebounds sitting at plus 104 live
talk to me talk to the people
do you like this one
i really don't to be honest with you
because i think one of the things the
nuggets have to do differently tonight
is rebound better uh jokic cannot get
all the rebounds himself you've got to
have guys like uncle jeff
aaron gordon being a little bit more
aggressive under the basket and getting
some of those rebounds to help jokic out
draymond hasn't even hit this number
once facing the nuggets this season so i
don't think it's going to happen tonight
so i don't really love this spot for
draymond green i think he has a big game
tonight i'm just not sure it's a big
rebounding game so i'm gonna say it's
not a lock
i'm right there with you liv now granted
draymond absolutely can go grab seven
rebounds tonight but am i putting my
money on it i do not think so
simply because i think draymond is going
to be exerting a lot of energy live on
the defensive side of the ball guarding
nicola jokic but
also liv
after the offensive shot goes up
draymond has to rebound he has to i mean
not rebound but he has to box out nicole
jokes he has to box him out
in order for him not to grab a rebound
and i just think that that's gonna
expend a lot of his energy so with that
all being said seven rebounds i'm just
not gonna put my money on it granted he
absolutely can go get it but you also
mentioned liv he hasn't done this
against the nuggets all year
so i'm simply staying away but let me
see what the people are talking about
let me see what they are talking about
rondon 22 says i'm rocking with liv
under dre will have six plus assists
i like that uh let's move on because
finally we have clay thompson to make
over three threes sitting at minus 128
live you know the people know how i feel
about three pointers made other than
steph
curry but we're talking about his
brother here his splash brother
clay thompson
liv do you think clay can go get it done
tonight
yeah of course i mean he's he's been
he's shot very well from the three-point
line versus the nuggets this year and
like i said in the playoffs alone the
nuggets are giving up or allowing the
most three-pointers to their opponent
which are the warriors and that's just
probably the worst spot you could be in
to give up the most three-pointers the
last team you want to face is a team
like the warriors uh klay thompson is
that guy we've talked about it many
times on this show we know he will
consistently put the three-point shots
up so that is not anything to ever worry
about he will continue to get the shots
up so three plus for him tonight i think
it's a lock
liv i'm right there behind you i mean
klay thompson steph curry uh jordan
poole they've been reigning threes this
whole playoffs against the nuggets uh
but clay had three last game had five
the first game i'm right there behind
you we know clay is going to put up the
shots head he attempted eight threes
last game attempted ten threes the first
game we know he's gonna put up the shots
clay go make three i am riding you know
who else is scoring threes tonight
they'll live you heard it here first
jordan poole and steph curry cause
fanduel is offering a custom vr betting
boost for all three to have
two plus three pointers made and for my
golden state warriors to win
it's boosted from plus 125 up to plus
175 live talk to me talk to the people
how you feeling about this one
this is one of those bets i look at and
i go it's too good to be true it's just
too good to be true i mean yes the
splash triplets
of course you expect them to have two
plush threes and steph curry jordan cool
i mean they could do that
in their sleep they wake up and they're
good for three plus threes on any given
day but i really like the nuggets to put
up a fight in this game so i could see
the threes hitting but the warriors not
winning is what i could see i just it's
too good to be true this is where my
better brain looks at it and goes that
kind of value for something that just
seems so easy it's kind of a stay away
bet for me because again i'm rocking
with my nuggets in this one so i'm
hoping this boost is inaccurate that's
what i'm hoping
liv is rocking with the home team and i
i can't even be mad liv i honestly i
can't be mad
i just only think i can do is wish you
and your nuggets the best because it
hasn't been we needed
as of late but uh what do you guys think
in the comments are you guys writing i'm
actually in the comments because i'm
giving away some of those shorts i see
jessie bolanos easy money greg let's go
uh shout out to you jesse i also see
evan mobley stands lock it up warriors
will win four-game sweep the nugget
curry will carry the squad shout out to
you evan moly uh i got one more jesse
i mean one more jesse jesse brought you
jesse bonos he's back into the comments
uh
you're you're you're getting the shorts
jesse but i got ryan cosix ryanco 6 says
br can i get my jersey that i won guess
what you're winning some some uh shorts
right now so so we hit us up for that
jersey and those shorts um
it's time lift it's time to build the br
betting custom same game parlay which
you can ride with us on fanduel tonight
we're at tonight we're looking at the
timberwolves grizzlies game and i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell me what they think which legs are
locked which legs are not live let's get
right into it we're starting off with
your mvp bet he gave it a good run
still might be able to win it but who
knows john moret to score 25 plus points
tonight do you like this or
do you not
love it i think we got a really big game
between john moran and anthony edwards
so love this leg
whoa i mean you mentioned his name
anthony edwards so let's pull him up on
the screen because we're going to talk
about them anthony edwards to score 25
plus points tonight
you said we're gonna have a good game by
these two so is that confirming anthony
edwards over 25 the nightlife
yes it is i love this one as well love
it
liv likes it i love it we're moving on
the cat carl anthony towns two plus
three pointers made is he gonna stay out
of foul trouble liv
talk to me talk to the people do you
think cat can go make two threes tonight
i mean you said it if he can stay out of
foul trouble and play smart basketball
not hard basketball i think that we
absolutely will see him hit this two
plus threes i mean he did win the
three-point contest as i mentioned
earlier so he's fully capable i do think
that if the timberwolves start to um
have any sort of deficit versus the
grizzlies you'll see these guys putting
up more three-pointers carl anthony
towns will be one of them but again that
foul trouble
that's that's the tricky thing about
carl anthony towns right now but foul
trouble aside i do think he hits two
plus threes
liv is rocking with it let's move on to
jared jackson jr
we need him to get two blocks this game
live do you think he can go and get
those two blocks tonight
yeah i think he probably feels very
under underestimated in terms of
defensive how he's played defensively
obviously marcus smart just won
defensive player of the year i think
jaren jackson jr was snubbed of being in
the conversation at all
he was averaging this throughout the
regular season so two plus blocks for
him
i'm not worried about that at all i feel
like he can get that in his sleep so i
love this leg as well
likes it all right that wraps up the
parlay but let's pull up the ticket
because if you go put a hundred dollars
down i want to show you how much money
you can be walking away with today there
it is you go put a hundred dollars down
you are walking away with 488
and don't forget about the change 29
cents uh speaking of moran and edwards
our friend over at fanduels are hooking
us up yet again today we've got a job
marant and anthony edwards to score 18
or more combined points in the first
quarter boosted
from plus 150 to plus 200 lift talk to
me talk to the people what do you think
and are you taking it
you know i think it's worth a sprinkle i
mean we have seen john marant in a lot
of games take a little bit of time to
heat up
usually in that towards the end of that
second quarter or even in the second
half is when you really start to see him
play great but i do see a big game from
both of these guys young superstars
playing very competitive and exciting
basketball right now so 18 plus points
in the first quarter i do think this is
a high scoring affair so
i like it i think it's worth a sprinkle
at plus 200 you can't really pass it up
definitely worth a sprinkle
live is sprinkling believe let's let's
get back to the matter at hand let's
focus in let's get back to this parlay
what are you grading
the same game parlay
yeah you know what i really like this
same game parlay because i think this is
going to be an exciting game
an even more exciting series between the
timberwolves and the grizzlies so i'm
going to give this parlay an a minus i
really like it i think both edwards and
marant go off john or jiren jackson jr
has a really big defensive game and car
anthony towns um steps in and keeps the
timberwolves in this one with some with
some hot threes so i'm giving it an a
minus i like it
liv's giving it an a minus i'm feeling
good about that uh
i'm in the comments right now because
i'm giving away shorts and a jersey lift
i see zaddy three says uh maybe third
quarter but not first
he's fading that pick but guess what
we're gonna give you good vibes for the
bad vibes you said we're gonna sing you
good vibes you are walking away with
some shorts of your choice
uh here we go enough said enough said is
in the comments
um saying sprinkle it shout out to you
enough said you were also walking away
with some shorts and now it's time to
give away this jersey live and i am in
the
comments and i see
go garden says eight plus easy hit no go
garden no we we can't give you that
uh i i see
jay
vernon 83 and liv
we're gonna do we're gonna give uh
good vibes to people that send us bad
vibes here jeremy says fade the boost no
we're not fading the boost but guess
what we're gonna do we're gonna send you
a jersey of your choice we're gonna send
you good vibes for sending us bad vibes
but alright liv you know what's coming
you already know what's coming i gotta
talk to you about my warriors
and your nuggets before we get into this
though let's take a look at the updated
series odds live do not be alarmed you
guys still have a chance don't be
alarmed whatever
i mean i don't know my warriors are
looking pretty good right now
i just want to check in with you liv how
are you feeling about your nuggets do
you actually think that they can make a
comeback in this series
you know here's the deal i
i love my nuggets i love jokic um
right now they don't have any momentum
in this series and that's just the fact
and it is really hard to face a team
like the warriors that is in full health
that has the splash triplets that has
draymond green on defense um when you
don't have any momentum there is only so
much that nikola jokic can do by himself
he is that guy yes there's no denying
that nicole yokic is a solid player
obviously he's been in mvp conversation
all season long rightfully so but there
is only so much that he can do by
himself and right now the nuggets just
don't have momentum he doesn't have help
um it's really tough to not have help on
a team like when you're facing a team
like the warriors you need we need aaron
gordon to be a whole lot more um
aggressive on offense will barton
definitely had his moments where he was
heating up i think monte morris can do a
little bit more facilitating um
but it's tough when nicole yokic is the
one guy you trust the most so you're
constantly feeding him the ball he runs
out of steam i don't know if you saw the
meme of him sitting on the bench and
someone said wow the warriors are really
putting him through it because he looked
wrecked and it's because he's doing it
all himself so i think one of the things
that i would love to see a little bit
differently in this game is hopefully
jokic getting a few more foul calls i
think he habitually does not get the
calls that he deserves um and and it's
and it's tough on him because i then he
grows frustrated and he gets ejected and
the nuggets cannot afford to have yoga
dejected so we just cannot have that
again but
the main character is nicole yokic and
he just can't do it alone so they have
got to step up today i'm sure your
conversation about the the warriors is
going to be a whole lot more fun than
what i just said
i mean i absolutely i even have a
highlight package that i want to refer
to
for this live
because
the way the warriors have been playing i
mean let's start off with with that's
that's yokis that's your team that's
that's your team no we need to get to
the warriors we got to get to the
warriors highlight package there it is
uh
that's that's looney hold on no that's
still joking that's still jokic he's
dominating they still have jokic on the
screen
they still have jokic but anyway jordan
poole he's been showing up in the
playoffs he's been absolutely showing up
in the playoffs he's turning into a star
there it is with the tween hold on hold
on let me step back tween tween stand
back pop there he is liv i mean he's
been doing that to you guys
for the last two games is he gonna
continue it tonight i don't see anything
changing as to why not he would not be
doing this tonight he's been going crazy
uh let's talk about the sixth man of the
year possibly steph curry coming off the
bench with 34 in the last game
liv he's going to come off the bench
tonight and i don't think anything is
going to change in the game plan if it
ain't broke
do not fix it also i just got an update
on my phone live i just got an update on
my phone
stephen curry is playing more minutes
tonight
than he played in the first two games so
look out please look out for that but uh
but enough of our tastes we want to hear
from you guys down no teams that are
down 02 in the playoffs
with the game three at home are 80 and
38 against the spread since 2005 that's
68
people so we asked you in the app if
you're riding the nuggets plus two and a
half tonight
and here are the results liv
there they are and i would say liv i
would say the people that are not
writing are very very
smart what is your interpretation of uh
the poll that's right here on the screen
listen you say that 67
is
is you know smart people and they you
know might be i'm not gonna tell anyone
they're not smart but uh i'm saying i'm
fading the public 67 versus 33
same way you're fading the public with
your timberwolves bet i am fading the
public with this bet nuggets plus two
and a half i think that actually helps
my case because you know everyone sees
steph curry's playing more minutes the
public's gonna hammer the warriors live
moods is staying true to her nuggets
will it bite her in the butt maybe i
like that but only time will tell i'm
fading the public for now
hey hey you gotta ride or die liv and i
hey every you know how many times i'm
riding with the warriors uh so i'm
riding with my team and you ride with
your team i am not mad at you but we
heard what you guys said in the app now
we want to know what you guys think in
the comments
are you riding with my warriors or are
you riding with liv and the nuggets and
actually think that they can come back
i'm in the comments because i'm giving
away some hoodies and please do not tell
me that i'm looking at comments of
people saying that the nuggets can come
back because i actually do not think
that's gonna happen liv but i got j
hearn in the comments saying greg your
warriors actually might win the title
this year book andrew middleton and
jernett struggling and the warriors have
found health at the perfect time i'm
loving the warriors right now to win it
they're playing great basketball and
healthy love the fresh cut appreciate
you brother jay hearn you are walking
away
with some hoodies uh let me see another
one
let me see another let me see another
take i see visionary says warriors all
day shout out to you uh rhino ryan ko
six says warriors take the series in a
sweep sorry liv
uh
yeah
sweep the nug sweep the nugs richie 21
everybody that i mentioned you guys all
are walking away with hoodies live
i'm sorry i'm outnumbered you know they
they spoke
yeah just just a little bit just this is
a little outnumbered you're you're the
underdog today but that that's okay i am
that's okay we like underdogs here on
this show but we talked to you guys
about the warriors nuggets series but
let's take a look at the rest here are
the current odds of each series
there they are
uh you see dallas at the top plus 172
followed by minnesota
they can possibly win tonight and those
odds might change chicago they got the
big win yesterday live new orleans
coming off of a big win brooklyn plus
340 taking it back home down 0-2 atlanta
uh denver uh
and toronto sitting at plus 2500 lyft do
you see any underdogs that you could
potentially
make a comeback
or that you can potentially see make a
comeback in their series
yeah i mean not really a comeback
because the series is tied but getting
minnesota at plus 198 i don't mind that
at all like i said series is tied
they're now gaining that home court
advantage tonight so i would definitely
take minnesota right now but i've been
saying it for some time now and i can't
tell you why i said it or what feeling i
had but i said very early on in the
season there was a part of me that felt
like the suns were going to choke in the
playoffs i just said it and now
obviously we're getting word that devin
booker's hamstring injury is a little is
maybe a little bit more serious than we
thought so i would say sprinkling on the
pelicans at plus 265 before
we know any confirmation on denver devon
booker's injury because that may be
subject to change um i don't mind
sprinkling on the pelicans right now
just a little bit
i like that liv i mean devin booker is a
big asset to that son's team and he's
down with a hammy injury those aren't
easy to come back from uh but i want to
talk about a team that's down 02.
honestly i thought the odds might be
better than what they are but the
brooklyn nets odds are looking mighty
mighty juicy liv people seem to forget
ben simmons
is is is on their team and i'm hearing
reports that he's gonna be actually
playing in these playoffs uh so kd had a
bad game last game so did kyrie irving
they're taking it back to brooklyn
sitting at plus 340.
i mean we're talking about the brooklyn
nets we're talking about one of the best
players in the game in kevin durant with
kyrie irving and ben simmons is gonna be
mixed into it oh my gosh i mean i like
the odds i like the odds we know what
that celtics defense do but i i just
like the odds there's a lot of firepower
on that brooklyn team especially with
ben simmons coming back so uh give me
those odds and plus i don't want to see
boston in the finals as a warrior fan if
if they they get past brooklyn i would
say they would have a good chance but i
don't want to see boston celtics in
their defense in the finals as a warrior
fan so let's go brooklyn let's go
brooklyn uh let me get into the comments
let me get into the comments
because uh
i need to figure out what they're
talking about ryan says do not take the
next celtics are gonna cook them shout
out to you ryan you're walking away with
the hoodie for fate of me uh lebron
money lebron money pals are very
underrated sons without the book are
very
suspect yes lebron money uh he's
agreeing with you liv shout out to you
you are walking away with a hoodie uh
live we reached the end
of the show it's been fun having you
back thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel remember
what you learned today the three by two
parlay is a lock the br betting same
game parlay is a lock we will be back
next monday giving away more hoodies
more jerseys and of course more lots if
you want a prize we will dm you
alongside live moves i'm greg ivory we
are leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you